[Music]
on this monday night fighting the fifth
wave
a record rush of covid patients in
hospitals and staff out sick i actually
have some people coming in from from
retirement and to help out who is
hospitalized as facilities are pushed
closer to the brink back to school i'm
excited about it students return to the
classroom even as covid cases climb a
heart-stopping rescue after a plane
crash on a railroad
[Music]
and remembering bob saget the tv dad who
tugged at the heartstrings i love you
too
and the comedian who pushed boundaries
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us hospitals in parts of canada are
reporting record numbers of patients
with covid19 as the omicron fueled fifth
wave threatens to overwhelm the health
care system take a look at this spike
over the past week canada's covet 19
hospitalizations have now climbed to new
heights with more than six thousand
patients hospitals in quebec ontario and
new brunswick have been hit particularly
hard and the number of patients
requiring intensive care is also up but
remains below levels seen last spring as
hospitals struggle to cope the big
question of course is when will this
latest wave reach its peak as abigail
beeman reports in our top story tonight
some areas are desperate for help
with staff sick leaves five times higher
than usual and all but critical surgery
shut down a hospital system serving the
southwestern ontario communities of
sarnia and lambton county issued an open
letter urging people to get vaccinated
and stay home a lot of people are doing
overtime or coming in from vacations to
backfill actually have some people
coming in from from retirement and to
help out chief of staff dr mike haddad
says things are now stabilizing slightly
he's hoping the impact of omicron will
peak in a week or two according to
ontario data there are 429 adults in icu
with covid that's about the same number
as this time last year but it's half as
many as the third waves peak in may but
that was the peak we don't know our peak
yet those on the front line say a few
things are different this fifth time
around including more staff off sick or
on isolation and fewer beds due to
attrition the province has said that we
have more beds because they've opened
more but functionally and by functional
i mean having a nurse to staff that bed
and look after that patient we have far
less than we did so a combination of
those things that's making it harder
with less functional beds and the
inability to send patients to other
hospitals to manage dr alex patel says
only about 40 percent of his icu
patients are fully vaccinated many with
chronic health conditions and none are
boosted people that have severe things
are battling like immunosuppression from
a cancer disease we do see those
patients as well but we're seeing those
even that have more
long-term conditions like diabetes and
obesity come in quebec and new brunswick
saw record hospitalizations over the
weekend nursing is a very empathetic
profession and right now i'd say it's
more apathy than there are empathy there
because of the sheer exhaustion that
they are faced with 8 to 12-hour nursing
shifts that stretch to 36 while quebec
remains the only province with a curfew
i think it's a reasonable assumption end
of january is when we would start to see
the benefit of the public health
measures people everywhere wonder when
the wave will crest i would say
potentially by the end of january we
could be out of our largest number
of cases harder to track exactly with
inaccurate case numbers due to less
testing in many parts of canada
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the united states has just set a new
record for covid19 hospitalizations
according to reuters there are now more
than 132
600 people infected in hospital that
surpasses the previous record set last
january hospitalizations have doubled in
the u.s in just the past three weeks
and against that backdrop of climbing
covid cases most canadian children
return to school today after an extended
winter break for students in central and
eastern canada classes are virtual for
at least one more week well in the west
schools reopened to in-person learning
but as heather york's west explains for
some students that return didn't last
long
after a very long and very cold covered
christmas break calgary schools are back
in session i'm excited about it like and
especially for my son because you know
he's missing a lot of the socialization
aspect of it all they want to see their
friends
they haven't seen them for
quite a few weeks now but the return of
in-person learning across bc and alberta
comes as omicron cases continue to rise
and school-age children are nowhere near
immune approximately 25 to 35 children
per day are testing positive at the
alberta children's hospital right now
and that's a dramatic spike from where
we were with any of the other waves
where the peak was generally around four
to five children per day dr stephen
friedman does not believe schools should
move to remote learning but he does
worry about the variants rapids spread
i'm glad they are back in school now um
and they are doing in person learning
but i think that that should be a last
resort and we really do need to restrict
other
um
places venues and
where individuals are contracting
omicron otherwise schools may not be
able to stay open for long by noon
monday with a shortage of more than 300
staff the calgary board of education
moved five classes online
something canadian families east of
saskatchewan were having to deal with
already it's very hard for the kids to
follow and engage with
especially when they're special ed
students right with four kids on the
autism spectrum suzel muniz is hopeful
ontario kids will return to in-person
learning next week as planned in toronto
the emphasis is on vaccines that booster
effort is continuing non-stop in the
face of the omicron variant along with
our push to get kids vaccinated and to
help education and child care workers to
get vaccinated so that the province and
school boards can get back to in-person
learning on january the 17th there is
widespread consensus across medical
professionals that for the social and
emotional health and well-being of kids
getting and keeping schools open should
be priority number one
especially as we begin this third year
under covet 19. heather urex west global
news calgary
prime minister justin trudeau held a
teleconference today with many of the
country's provincial and territorial
premiers it's their first meeting since
mid-december and since the omicron
variant pushed case counts and
hospitalizations to record highs our
chief political correspondent david
aiken has been tracking the meeting for
us today so david what was on the agenda
well the first thing the prime minister
justin trudeau wanted to do was to go
around the table see how all the
premiers are coping with omicron that's
top of mind at provincial capitals but
the prime minister also wanted to get a
sense of where future requests for
federal assistance might come from right
now for example we've got the canadian
army in quebec helping out with the
vaccine program there and the pm wanted
to find out what's sort of in the
pipeline might be in the pipeline down
the road and that came with a warning
that there are only so many canadian red
cross workers only so many medic or army
personnel and have to be smart with that
resource the prime minister also talked
about support for small business of
course there's a slimmed down version of
that canadian wage subsidy program and
the prime minister wanted to find out
from premiers how that was going and
whether or not they need to make any
adjustments
and there's also been a lot of
speculation david about whether ottawa
might push to make vaccines mandatory
particularly after the health minister
john eve duclo raised that very issue
last week so was that on the table at
all today
no not really and you know what that
comment from duklow was really the
health minister shooting from the hip
that's what one source in a premier's
office told me there's really no serious
federal proposal to do that and in fact
as soon as duklow said what he said two
premiers alberta's jason kennedy and
saskatchewan scott moe came out right
away and said no way no how they're dead
set against any broad-based mandatory
vaccination program
right so some premiers clearly don't
want vaccine mandates so what do they
want what were the provinces and
territories asking for today david
well they want more money for health
care jeff and you know this is something
they've asked about every time they meet
with the pm going back 18 months with
not much success but one other thing two
premiers kenny and ontario's doug ford
also pressed the pm on anti-viral pills
now these are pills that people take as
soon as you are feel symptoms from kovid
studies show they can prevent serious
illness they're approved for use in some
countries they're not approved yet for
use in canada and both kenny and ford
think these anti-viral pills
particularly the one from pfizer could
be key tools to keep people out of
hospitals and so they were asking health
canada quickly please approve these
pills jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
novak djokovic has won his high profile
court battle to stay in australia and
play in the australian open a judge
reinstated the tennis star's visa it
means djokovic who is not vaccinated
against covet 19 won't be deported at
least for now but as eric sorenson
explains the world number one isn't in
the clear just yet
the image many thought not possible
novak djokovic on the tennis court in
melbourne
his fans couldn't be happier for his
family vindication but novak is only
fighting for
the liberty of choice djokovic's choice
was not to get vaccinated the australian
government overturned his medical
exemption and prepared to deport him but
an australian judge found djokovic was
not treated fairly asking what more
could this man have done and ruled he
could stay
djokovic posted he was grateful and said
despite all that has happened i want to
stay and try to compete at the
australian open many australians aren't
so happy i don't think you should come
and play i don't think anyone should be
treated any differently to anyone else
it didn't help djokovic's image that he
was shown in public last month without a
mask one day after testing positive for
kovid i think it's ridiculous no one
cares as much about anything else except
for a tennis player
it's so dumb
good evening there are major
developments in the novak djokovic case
in many cases people are role models and
it's newsworthy and to the ordinary you
know citizen this just went beyond the
pale why does he get special treatment
the government i think want to be seen
to be doing the right thing applying the
same standard to everyone djokovic's win
in court is a big moment for the
anti-vaccine movement you know what i
worry about is it could be considered a
victory for the unvaccinated and what i
worry about is it could deepen the
polarization of this situation
australia's immigration minister could
still have djokovic deported his mother
hopes he can just get back to tennis i
just hope that
it will stay like this
that he will be free and he will play
the australian open is a glorious
opportunity for djokovic to overtake
rivals rafael nadal and roger federer
for the most grand slam titles in
history he makes his own decisions nadal
who said last week djokovic knew the
rules now says justice has spoken and
djokovic should play
the big names are already preparing
top canadians buoyed by their big atp
cup victory on the weekend will be among
the challengers to try to topple
djokovic the old-fashioned way on the
tennis court eric sorensen global news
toronto
a rescue with only seconds to spare
coming up the frantic moments to save a
man from an oncoming train
plus ancient reptile remains the giant
skeleton just unearthed after 180
million years
[Music]
welcome back a daring rescue by police
officers in los angeles was caught on
camera a pilot whose plane crash-landed
onto railroad tracks was pulled to
safety just seconds before a train
slammed into the wreckage and a warning
some of the images here may be difficult
to watch
wow you can hear the impact that sent
debris flying nearly hitting bystanders
in the area but the injured pilot there
was pulled out just in time by police he
was the only person on board the plane
and according to local media he was
treated for cuts and bruises and is now
in stable condition
to an update now on sunday's deadly
high-rise fire in new york city
officials have revised the number of
dead to 17 that's two fewer than
previously thought
mayor eric adams says nine adults and
seven children were killed at least 13
people are now in life-threatening
condition in hospital the fire
commissioner says the fire was sparked
by a faulty space heater in a bedroom
flames damaged only a small part of the
building but smoke spread through the
apartment's open door choking stairwells
and escape routes
this is a global tragedy because of the
bronx in new york city is representative
of the ethnicities and cultures across
the globe
and so everyone is feeling the pain of
what we are experienced
a task force will now investigate any
failures in the building's code
displaced residents are being offered
hotel rooms and president joe biden is
also pledging federal support it is the
deadliest fire in new york city in
nearly 32 years
convicted killer and wealthy real estate
heir robert durst has died in prison
durst had long been suspected of killing
three people including his first wife
who went missing back in 1982. the
allegations against him gained renewed
attention after a 2015 hbo documentary
last fall durst was sentenced to life in
prison for the killing of his best
friend and he was then indicted for the
murder of his wife officials say durst
died this morning at a prison hospital
in california he was 78. the u.s says
there has been no major breakthrough
after the first day of high-level talks
with russia over the ukraine border
crisis
russian and american diplomats held
face-to-face talks at the u.s diplomatic
mission in geneva that meeting is the
first of three to be held this week
russia has amassed more than a hundred
thousand troops along its border with
ukraine both washington and kyiv believe
the country is preparing to invade but
today russia's deputy foreign minister
said there was no reason to fear an
escalation at the border
in military-ruled myanmar aung san
tsuchi has been sentenced to four more
years in prison the ousted civilian
leader was found guilty of illegal
possession of walkie-talkies and
violating covid restrictions it's one of
a series of cases brought by the
military which her supporters say are
bogus and politically motivated last
month suchi was sentenced to two years
in prison in a separate case if found
guilty on all charges she could spend
the rest of her life in detention
still ahead platinum plans how
buckingham palace is preparing to
celebrate a historic anniversary
[Music]
in four weeks from now queen elizabeth
will have been the reigning british
monarch for exactly 70 years her
unprecedented platinum jubilee will be
celebrated in the uk and right across
the commonwealth buckingham palace has
now released a full schedule of events
from a four-day weekend to a special
nationwide bake-off redmond shannon has
the goods
the world hasn't seen this since
november the queen fulfilling her royal
duties in person she pared back her
schedule last year after spending time
in hospital to recuperate and perhaps to
prepare for a big year ahead this is
something that we all need it's
something that britain and the
commonwealth can rejoice over no british
monarch has ever reached their 70th
platinum jubilee the full details of the
british plans for the year are now
public they include a four-day holiday
weekend in june
a full post-pandemic return of her
official birthday ceremony the trooping
of the color
a party and a concert at buckingham
palace echoing her 2002 golden jubilee
one of the most magnificent streets in
the whole united kingdom with a pageant
along london's famous mao
and that forms the finale piece
for the whole weekend it's likely many
events will have contingencies for
pandemic restrictions and for the
queen's health bearing in mind she's
going to be 96 it will undoubtedly be
done
with the advice of doctors and with
great care on your marks get set fake
equally exciting for many a competition
to invent a dessert that will become the
platinum pudding the appeal is baked in
a judge from the great british bake off
will determine the winner
hundreds of beacons will be lit across
britain plus one in each commonwealth
capital in canada at ottawa city hall
troops of town criers including niagara
falls patrick ciriani will shout a
proclamation in unison
a tribute to the venerable monarch who
first visited the falls four months
before she became queen i have a lot of
respect for queen elizabeth ii she's the
only
monarch i've ever known
since i was born remarkably that's true
for about 85 percent of brits too
redmond shannon global news london
a team of british archaeologists is
celebrating what's being called one of
the greatest fossil finds in uk history
this massive ichthyosaur skeleton was
discovered in a water reservoir it's
about 10 meters long and is believed to
be 180 million years old the sea
predator is commonly known as a sea
dragon it had a similar body shape to
dolphins ichthyosaur remains have been
found before but this is the largest and
most complete fossil ever found in the
uk
remembering bob saget
up next the comedy world mourns the loss
of a television icon
[Music]
the entertainment world has lost another
star bob saget was found dead in a hotel
room in florida yesterday police say
there were no signs of foul play or
drugs in the 1990s saget was one of the
biggest stars on television and as mike
armstrong explains the actor comedian
had just launched a comedy tour and his
death came as a shock to fans everywhere
ladies and gentlemen
bob sagan
it was a life lived to make people laugh
something bob saget did any way he could
and now they're taking a break
in the 90s he was working 80 hours a
week splitting his time between hosting
america's funniest home videos whatever
happened starring in the sitcom full
house are we going to have fun or what
neither was quite his comedy cup of tea
you comb your hair differently no
you would joke his favorite episode of
full house was the last i need you to
like me real bad because i have no act
and i have no life and i have no future
now he did other shows acted directed
and produced but saggett's first love
was stand up in fact he just kicked off
a new comedy tour he did two nights in
florida over the weekend and was excited
posting to instagram just hours before
his death i'm back in comedy like i was
when i was 26 i guess i'm finding my new
voice and loving every moment of it
immediately the comedy world was in
mourning remembering not just a talent
but a kindness someone who always sought
to spread smiles the last thing he would
want is comedians crying he would want
us to be laughing but right now i can't
laugh
i'm still crying
also remembering saget on this day a
charity he worked with for years after
losing a sister to a skin disease he
raised millions to fight it srfcchc.org
doesn't sound as simple as i thought but
even that was something saggett could
joke about here goes nothing on tv he
was straight laced okay i'll go what the
hell i got no life on stage he had no
boundaries he would say he was dirty but
never mean i'm 12 years old and i
learned a bunch of words no saget used
humor to make a living but also as a
coping mechanism the more uncomfortable
the easier he could turn something into
a joke he is a best-selling author like
when he wrote a book and dedicated it to
his late mother and his close friend the
late norm mcdonald read the inscription
this is for you mom dolly saget 1925 to
2014. it was another chance to get alive
that's made up she didn't die
bob sagan was 65.
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm jeff semple tonight's
your canada is this sun dog over
broadview saskatchewan thanks for
watching have a great night
[Music]